nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir physique le fait
bonsoir
alors philippe le fait dans les années
90 2000 vous épanouissez dans votre vie
vous présenter le journal télévisé vous
animé l'émission littéraire des mots de
minuit vous êtes l'une des pièces
maîtresses de la rédaction de france 2
mais en 1996 c'est le drame vous et
votre compagne avait une petite fille
qui ne peut et ne pourra jamais parler
cette histoire vous le raconter dans un
livre intitulé étude ans lou publié chez
stock et à 20h dans salut les terriens
[Musique]
philippe lefebvre bonsoir à
vous n'êtes ni le 27 décembre 1953 à
hénin-liétard qui deviendra hénin
beaumont dans le pas de calais votre
grand père était mineur votre père
comptable dans les houillères votre mère
employée à la poste vous grandissez à
noyelles-sous-lens un gros village au
coeur du pays minier vous dites de chez
moi je voyais la montagne de charbon le
terry wey ensuite votre trajectoire et
celle de l'ascenseur social
lycée condorcet à lens bac littéraire
doctorat en relations internationales
école supérieure de journalisme à lille
et la bourse europe 1 on avait droit à
un stage on avait droit à un voyage suis
allé en chine avec jean michel jarre
ouais super pour moi et j'étais embauché
voilà et là vous devez dans quelques
années une pièce maîtresse de la
rédaction d'europe 1 alors vous mariée
une première fois fin des années 70 et
puis après une petite fille et 15 ans de
mariage c'est la séparation en 1986 vous
êtes recruté par antenne 2 comme grand
reporter au service étranger vous
couvrez la nouvelle calédonie la chute
du président des philippines marcos avec
les chaussures de sa femme imelda
en 1990 vous présenter le 13 heures de
la 2è joker du 20h et présentateur de
l'édition de la nuit et là
vous faites un reportage à la
vidéothèque de paris et vous rencontrer
la responsable de la com pomme beso oui
c'est une rencontre c'est une révélation
c'est l'amour fou un amour aussi
extrêmement tumultueux cinq ans après
vous vous séparez mais bon pour
reviendra ensemble je rassure les
téléspectateurs
et quand vous vous retrouvez c'est
autour du désir de faire un enfant alors
il faudra faire appel à la science oui
ça a été compliqué ouais les cigognes et
est paresseuse alors pendant la
grossesse de pommes le gynéco prédit un
gros bébé oui mais le 6 juin 1996 à 2
heures du matin la maternité des lilas
pomme accouche d'une petite fille de 45
centimètres et de 2,2 kg qui s'appelle
loup alors là c'est plus gros bébé là
non c'est pour nous un gros
apprentissage du bambou si le bambou à
un coût c'est du coup combien sur la
tête ouais et surtout le comment je vais
dire là la surprise d'une équipe
médicale qui nous a d'un seul coup
retourner son inquiétude il ya la
pédiatre qui débarque et vous dit votre
petite fille à la une drôle de tête
n'était un peu marri si je vais à dire
de fin d'avoir à supporter en plus
l'inquiétude du l'équipe médicale alors
loué placé en couveuse et là commence
pour vous et pour pomme l'angoissent
d'avoir un enfant anormal dans les jours
qui suivent aucun médecin ne parvient à
faire un diagnostic précis
le seul avis que vous recueillez c'est
celui de la mère de pommes qui est
médecin et qui vous dit lou n'est pas
mongolienne alors elle croit presque
vous faire plaisir mais se mouiller vous
fait rentrer vous et toute la famille
dans l'univers du handicap est dans la
spirale alors j'aime pas le jem pas
forcément le mot handicap oui je pense
qu'il faut dire singulier si on accepte
et tout le monde soit singulier
peut-être qu'on aurait la société un peu
un peu plus vite vers l'avant alors
amants vous êtes tellement des ans
paraît que vous envisagé d'envoyer un
pavé dans la vitrine du gynéco qui avait
diagnostiqué le jeu gros bébé il était
très fin est un peu trop sûr de lui je
me suis dit je vais me venger et pour
finir je vais pas réussi forcément en
danger puis j'ai pas trouvé de pavé
puisque la rue avait été bitumés way
lors de retour à la maison loup ne mange
pas elle pleure beaucoup nuitées jour ce
qui fait que la ramener à l'hôpital là
ça sera necker branle bas de combat les
médecins se succèdent les contrôles se
multiplient mais le diagnostic est
toujours le même pas de diagnostic et
bien nous ne mange pas il n'y a pas de
diagnostic c'est pire que tout ne pas
savoir
c'est pire que tout sauf qu on est dans
l'urgence de l'amour cet enfant qui sait
nous et ça ne peut être rien d'autre que
nous on n'en veut pas d'autres et il
faut faire avec lou et avec ce qu'elle
demande de soins particuliers pas plus
pas moins de retour à la maison pour
faire dormir loup vous êtes obligé de la
mettre sur un matelas incliné à 60%
attachés avec des épingles à nourrice
parce qu'elle régurgite en fait beaucoup
un avis de belles nuits ouais alors vous
dites nous vivions dans la peur de la
voir mourir un peu à 2 ans lou pèse 4
kilos donc ce qui est le poids des bébés
en général à la naissance elle régurgite
effectivement énormément son un
chauffage et brûlé par des remontées
acides
il faudra donc l'opérer et la nourrir à
l'aide d'une pompe gastrique relié à
l'estomac c'est en fait vous lever
toutes les nuits à deux heures pour
changer la poche de nourriture oui
absolument c'est une espèce de lait
concentré sucré parce qu'elle ne peut
rien prendre que que sa voix la mêlée
d'une vaillance extraordinaire parce que
le plus combatif à l'hôpital c'est
plutôt elle que nous à un moment vous
pensé quand même à vous [ __ ] en l'air
oui mais demain c'est une forme de
fantasme ça vous aider avait finalement
cette idée de mourir humain alors
évidemment dans un tel contexte le
couple tangue vous êtes souder le temps
de la lutte mais sitôt les crises
passées vous écrivez alors je dis au
passage que votre livre est
remarquablement écrit merci vous écrivez
chacun s'en retourne à son
bouillonnement solitaire oui parce que
quand vous avez dans ces moments là et
dans ces urgences là ce que moi j'ai
appelé à l'époque un enfant du sol au
plafond cet enfant qui occupe toute la
place abîme la relation d'un homme et
d'une femme même s'ils sont par ailleurs
père et mère alors loup à quatre ans
qu'on pomme et vous vous séparez loup
sort enfin de l'enfer de la pompe
gastrique elle peut désormais manger
normalement elle marche elle est
scolarisée dans un endroit
extraordinaire elle s'appelle gulliver
ou deux tiers des enfants sont normaux
si on peut dire ça et un tiers sont
singuliers c'est là où un jour vous
arrivez vous voyez loup qui mène la
danse quoi oui absolument alors là on se
dit tiens on a gagné puisque loup qui ne
marche pas forcément encore entraîne
toute là toute la lumière sur les faits
c'est tout le monde fait comme elle est
d'un seul coup elle a inversé les rôles
et les devenu leader bingo
malheureusement loup est toujours privé
de parole ce qui est extrêmement
paradoxal c'est que pomme et vous vous
êtes dans des métiers du mot un abcès
les électrices cherche midi vous faites
les mots de minuit donc vous êtes vous
parlez et votre enfant ne parle pas
belle la vie et facétieux il faut jamais
penser que les choses sont acquises vrai
loup vient d'avoir ses temps quand vous
découvrez le mac app ton alors le
makaton c'est un programme d' aide à la
communication qui associe les paroles
les signes et les pictogrammes et grâce
à ce système finalement une certaine
communication devient possible entre
vous louez dans la communication elle
entend tout elle n'est pas autiste bon
mais un moment elle bouillonne à
l'intérieur et donc il faut lui trouver
des moyens d'exprimer son angoisse pour
parler sinon elle pique des colères en
chinois le pique des colères et on va
voir que plus elle va aller dans ses
apprentissages divers et variés - ses
colères seront aux mairies ouais et et
on arrivera aujourd'hui à avoir un
échange qui est un échange bricoler vous
avez appris le langage des signes avec
pommes pour lui parler absolument alors
là vous réhabilité avec pommes et pierre
jour l'un des médecins généticien vous
appelle il vous dit on a trouvé le
handicap de loup est dû à un manque
d'adhérents dans le chromosome 12 alors
pour vous c'est très important parce que
c'est pas une maladie c'est un hasard
génétique rare génétique et donc ça
rassure les parents qui ne sont pas
porteurs et qui n'ont pas vraiment gay à
leurs enfants ouais cette fin cette
singularité cette particularité c'est le
hasard la ville aviva son couvre alors
aujourd'hui loup a beaucoup gagné en
autonomie elle fait ses courses au
supermarché elle prend le métro elle
sarah tease avec des gens de prendre le
métro sur trois stations donc un métro
qui parle puisqu'elle ne lui paraît une
pure analphabètes aujourd'hui 1 et mais
quand même elle sait où descend on se
retrouve au café pour boire un coca et c
est là toujours sur elle des éléments
qui permettent dé la son petit carnet
rouge les numéros de téléphone de ses
parents son portable avec un forfait
illimité donc c'est sympa aussi l écrit
commence à écrire des sms voilà ses
bisous salut comment ça va papa quant à
lui fait quel âge là 17 alors pomme et
vous avez fini par vous marier et ouais
et le jour du mariage vous avez dansé
tous les trois sur cette chanson
souviens plus du nom du vainqueur
ce dont je me souviens de ces amoureux
qui me regardait rien autour d'eux
il avait tendance sur dans un geste
alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça ce sont les six que vous faisiez ayew
pendant la chanson le jour du match et
qu'on a fait tous les trois ensemble et
voilà c'était une manière de faire un
clin d'oeil à nos amis une très jolie
phrase philippe vous dit lorsque l'on
accepte la vie comme elle est on peut
commencer en profiter il n'y a jamais eu
d'apitoiement ya jamais eu deux essais
on n'est pas non plus du genre à dire à
le handicap c'est quelque chose qui vous
nourrit qui vous apprend des choses non
c'est terriblement dur c'est
terriblement violent mais c'est
terriblement vivant ça vous oblige à
vivre et est à inventer et être des
pionniers et à trouver des trucs en
permanence à bricoler notre histoire
merci de votre témoignage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu